today my team PR shaki will be
presenting a problem statement ID 1554
which is about smart irrigation system
for precision farming nowadays water
scarcity is a major challenge in
agriculture leading to insufficient
water usage and reduced drop traditional
irrigation method often result in
overuse or underuse of water however we
have developed an smart irrigation
system that utilizes iot and
Technologies to monitor soil moisture
nutritional level and weather condition
this system will provide a realtime data
for Farmers enabling them to make
informed decision on irrigation
scheduling th optimizing water usage and
maximize crop yeld we have come with a
robotic car fixed with different sensors
to provide such as for soil testing soil
moisture soil temperature then NSP for
motion we will be using IR sensors for
paste I thermal camera for air humidity
and temperature dd22 for checking
nutritional level of soil NPK sensors
and for detecting rain rain sensors all
sensors are controlled by ESP 826 which
drives the car according to the data
described by the farmer the data
collected to an I blink platform which
is analyzed precisely by using aimf
these datas are shown to the former
using user interface which shows
temperature water level humidity GPRS
nutrition and insects according to these
analysis the motor that is connected to
our fertilizer pump is opened and closed
by one click of the farmer here we have
also use GPRS sensor to detect the
location of the car the robotic car
consists of omni wheel which is free to
move in any direction without any D here
we have also prepared a video for this
problem thank you